[Music]
the framework that most people have is
fast and me it's fast and what do I get
and it is obvious to me that the unlock
for the 90% in this room is slow and
then you got your perspective it is good
to be here hello everyone
[Applause]
please sit sit let's do this so the way
we structured today's talk is I'm going
to talk for 30 minutes and then we are
gonna do 30 minutes of Q&A which I think
are in the corners over there they'll
set that up but first of all thank you
so much for the warm welcome I'm super
excited to be here I touched down
earlier today and there's a lot of
different things I'd like to touch on
but what I'm gonna speak about is really
things that I hope lead to more detailed
questions when we get into the Q&A
session and so there's really two things
that I think about which is one of the
reasons I talk a lot about things like
clouds and dirt or macro micro or not
being half pregnant or in the middle is
I genuinely believe that when I analyze
things that have worked for me for the
businesses I admire for other people
that have created success I think that
you need to play in the edges what I
mean by that is upper funnel lower
funnel what I mean by that is brand and
sales what I mean by that is scalable
activities and then non-scalable
activities for me one of the more
interesting things I did today was on
the drive here for about 40 minutes
I was just replying to a bunch of
different texts that I've got from a
text platform that I've created one by
one every smart business
friend I have would consider it a waste
of time not a good use of my time and
for me those 39 to 44 people that
actually got a detailed answer it
created depth in the relationship that I
have with them I genuinely believe that
people struggle with scaleable not with
the scaling non-scalable behavior
I believe that anybody here who has more
than 10 employees does not spend enough
time in one-on-one meetings with those
employees or having a sense of what they
want not what we want out of those
employees and so I've been spending a
lot of time thinking about activities
that actually lead to what somebody
wants when I think about somebody buying
a ticket to an event like this and
spending all day it means that they're
looking for information they're looking
for a hack or an insight or a framework
that helps them succeed and for me the
reality is as my profile continues to
grow somebody asked me earlier today a
question that led me to answering most
people don't act on what I'm talking
about you know so much of what I'm
talking about is very based in patience
it's very based in grinding work ethic
work I'm so not interested in anything
short-term you know and I feel like
everyone is attracted to the next big
platform or blockchain and
cryptocurrency or cannabis or a quick
trade or investment let it be very clear
Sydney that the way I think about the
world sits in decades not in months
almost half the questions I got on text
and DM in the last month
were framed in a version of hey Gary Vee
how can I make a lot of money quickly
and I'm there may not be a single person
on earth that is worse at answering that
question than me
my ability or interest in creating quick
money is almost non-existent and I'm
fascinated by how few people win in
quick moves yet the majority of people
are looking for it
there is no system there is no passive
income framework there is no sure bet
there is no guaranteed return there is
lunch pail and hard hat day in and day
out grinding and trying to bring value
to the people that you're trying to sell
something to and it's in perpetuity and
so we are so fortunate to be living
during this time where the internet on
your phone has created such substantial
scale for all of us
none of our grandparents had the luxury
of being able to build something
significant that they could live off of
and the power of something that was in
their pocket and yet everybody is
looking for the why nots instead of the
whys meaning I am fascinated by the
ability right now of humans to demonize
technology kids should be off iPads more
social media leads to an anxiety and
negativity we we are demonizing these
technologies because what these
technologies are doing right now is
they're exposing us they're not changing
us Instagram and Facebook and Twitter
don't force you to be a [ __ ] on
their platforms we're doing that and so
we live in this time where there's so
much opportunity and let me tell you how
this opportunity works out in its most
simple every single person in this room
whether they're trying to build a
personal brand and speak in write books
or they're trying to sell their
new bikini brand direct-to-consumer or
their cereal or real estate or financial
advice or no running for mayor or
president whatever you're doing in this
room from that corner to that corner
unless you have the attention of people
and unless you articulate what you want
to happen in a form that makes them want
to act on it
you are completely irrelevant the reason
I pump out so much content in written
audio and video form every single day
across 10 different platforms including
podcast email and my text messaging
platform is because the cost of entry to
be successful in society is predicated
on communicating at scale if you do not
understand that part if you do not
understand that there's an enormous need
to make compelling content to excite
somebody to consider to do whatever
you're up to unless you understand that
framework you are outrageously
vulnerable just cuz you think your
videos are funny or good doesn't mean
they do just because you think you make
the best chocolate shake if nobody knows
about it it's not gonna matter so please
understand what the internet is actually
doing what the internet is actually
doing at scale is it's shrinking the
value of everything
besides communication if you're not
building brand or awareness you're
becoming irrelevant what's fascinating
to me about that is so many people have
those ambitions but they're not creating
the actions that lead to it I was on the
radio this morning when I first got here
and somebody called and said I'm trying
to build my whole business on the
Instagram in photography and I asked him
how many times a day are you posting he
said once and I said to myself you're
trying to build your entire life based
on Instagram and you genuinely believed
posting one time a day is going to be
the gateway to that I was looking at a
lot of people that were leaving comments
or tagging the
event all day and I went on their
Instagram accounts about 40 people I
would say during the day of those 40
people only two people actually replied
to people's comments on Instagram the
amount of people here that want to grow
on that platform yet the small community
that they have that actually reply to
their content they don't have time to
reply and say thank you or continue the
conversation fascinates the [ __ ] out of
me we are in the most selfish framework
society that I've ever seen every single
person is so focused on what they want
from other people yet they deploy no
value in return to the other person for
what they want the Gateway to everything
you're trying to get out of this
conference is empathy and being selfless
yet that is the least attractive thing
to most people people are so worried
about how they're gonna get to a
expensive watch or private plane or
fancy vacation that they're confused of
how you actually get there and so I am
unbelievably passionate in starting to
continue the process that I've been on
over the last 15 years which is to put
pressure on this room to understand
unless you're bringing value you will
become irrelevant because what the
internet also does is it allows every
one of us to play the reason so many
people ask me what the next big platform
is is because they're far more
interested in playing a game of being
first versus playing a game of being
best right now there are seven platforms
YouTube Facebook Twitter Linkedin
Instagram that and on and on that are at
enormous scale that if you were good at
it you would get enormous value you
would get unlimited customers you would
get unlimited opportunities
yeah day in and day out people continue
to not want to be what they need to be
which is let me remind everybody very
simply if you are not remarkable at
creating content that is post-produced
to understand the context of the
platform that you're posting on and more
importantly the psychology of people
when they're on it you will lose meaning
you can't post the same picture on
Twitter and Instagram and LinkedIn and
think you're gonna get the same result
people are in a different mindset also
those platforms work differently they
have different ways to format pictures
different lengths of creative this is
one masterful game of communication the
reason we know the people that we know
in history whether Muhammad Ali or
Gandhi is because they were great
communications hackers above and beyond
what they were actually doing for a
living
everybody here now has the luxury of
having the Internet be the platform that
they can communicate on yet we have
bum-rushed
into a game of hacking or looking for
shortcuts or the thing that will break
through versus becoming craftsmen and
crafts women on these platforms it has
become very clear to me especially
recently that a game of best at
communication is the reason that I get
the honor of standing here tonight that
I put in on godly amounts of hours
understanding these platforms and
people's behaviors on them that I lack
the fear of having a post you know where
I was about to go with that sentence I
just cut myself off because one of the
things that I'm most excited about in
the last decade in social media is
actually being tested here in Australia
which is Instagram eliminating like some
posts to me this is one of the great
moves in a long time in the industry
because so many people have become so
deeply insecure that all they really do
what their content is post things that
they know will get the most like
the amount of muscle dudes who want to
talk about other things that DM me and
say I want to talk about these other
things but when I post photos without my
shirt I get the most likes so I keep
doing it and the conversations of when I
asked him why do you do that and they
don't even know they're caught in the
machine of getting more likes than
talking about the thing they actually
give a [ __ ] about we are living in
unprecedented times every person in this
conference including myself is grossly
under estimating the Internet this is
the singular invention of the human race
it is the most important thing that has
happened to humans since the printing
press it has completely changed the
global political landscape it has
completely changed the leverage of human
beings ability there is literally
nothing stopping every person in this
room from getting whatever they want
because there is no man in the middle
the platform's have all the leverage and
the consumer in the end is the actual
punchline so here are the things that
are most passionate about hey if you are
capable of starting a podcast around the
thing you do I highly recommend you use
this talk to inspire to do so and let me
explain why I believe that podcasts have
almost like a triple hack to them number
1 podcasts are being consumed at a
remarkable rate how many people in this
audience please raise your hands listen
to podcasts on a weekly basis raise your
hands actually stand up I want everybody
to see this please stand up if you
listen to podcasts I don't want
everybody look around we're talking
about 90 percent of this audience 80
percent of this audience thank you
please sit if you can start a podcast
even if you have a thousand people
listening you don't have to be a top 100
podcast in the world you need to have
the people that you're trying to
actually reach if you have a podcast
what also happens at
Podcast is incredibly important if
you're thoughtful enough when you do
your podcast to also film it what ends
up happening is now you have video
content for YouTube and Facebook and
LinkedIn if you also are disciplined
enough to then transcribe the interview
you have with somebody you now have
written content for those platforms if
you're extremely thoughtful you invite
guests who you actually want to do
business with when you're cold calling
to do business they ignore you when you
invite somebody to be a guest on your
podcast they're flattered I highly
recommend if you've been debating it to
use this evening as the push to start
that podcast number two regardless of
what you do you started a shampoo brand
for fifteen year olds you have to start
looking at LinkedIn LinkedIn over the
last year and a half and I believe for
at least another year or two based on
the way I'm looking at it is acting more
like Facebook 2011 than any platform
I've seen prior it's been very
fascinating to watch LinkedIn be a place
where you don't have to just do business
content yes the psychology of people on
there is a little more business oriented
but if you were in the b2b business how
many people here consider themselves in
the b2b business raise your hand if
you're one more time a little higher if
you don't mind I mean if you are not
posting four or five six times a day
and when I say posting this goes back to
the way I framed up this conversation
you have to make content that brings
value to them isn't a sales pitch for
you
most of the content that I see on every
platform is so self-serving nobody gives
a [ __ ] nobody wants to be sold to
there's too many other options
this isn't late-night television or
infomercials where there's only 36
channels this is the internet it's
unlimited content and there's a lot of
good [ __ ] out there so if you're not
putting out good [ __ ] you're finished
you're not gonna will your way to
victory
LinkedIn for everybody who just raised
her hand on b2b is going to go away in
its organic reach just like Facebook and
it's RAM do you have to strike now
please have a very significant LinkedIn
strategy please start
finding a way to produce more content if
you don't know how if you don't know
what to say create a queue a framework
email blasts your consumers and ask them
what questions they have and then turn
that into content figure it out have
guests figure it out you have to
challenge so to me podcast and LinkedIn
are remarkably out of control how many
people sell a product on the internet
through Shopify are things that nature
sell something raise your hands for this
group I want to talk about influencer
marketing I believe the influencer
marketing is at a maturity level that a
lot of people think that it's now over
or it's too expensive or they missed it
my belief is that we're five seconds
into influencer marketing that
influencer marketing is here in
perpetuity because word of mouth is that
influencer marketing is unbelievably
underpriced if you're sophisticated on
your end and understand how to not
overpay and that if you sell any product
that you must absolutely get serious
about influencer marketing because over
every other option in communication when
done right at scale it returns the
biggest ROI the problem is most people
are chasing the wails of people that
have millions of followers and many of
those people are now overpriced because
the follow count is the metric that
they're selling against meanwhile with
my sneakers and my wine products many
people that have 3000 or 5000 or 8,000
people tend to be driving my biggest
results because they have deep engaged
audience an enormous trust in that
audience and so if you're on the
consumer side I highly recommend that
you go down that path
the luxury of being 43 years old and
operating businesses every day of my
life for over 20 years is the following
I operated prior to the internet being
at scale and mobile phones being at
scale what that means is when I did
direct mail and newspapers and
television and billboards to build my
dad's liquor store everything cost a lot
of money it was very expensive and if
you were at zero you had no [ __ ] shot
we sit here tonight with the internet at
scale that if you're here and you have
not started any of this and you've got
nothing going on that tomorrow at the
cost of zero only your sweat equity you
can start the process of building
something meaningful the excuses that
fly at scale to why we haven't or why
you haven't or why it hasn't happened is
very difficult for somebody like me to
swallow in a world where I didn't have
these options if I had [ __ ] eBay and
Instagram when I was 15 I would have
been a trillionaire by 19 we are sitting
in the easiest time to be a successful
entrepreneur in not so many words if
you're not successful right now you suck
and what I mean by that is we have a
frothy global economy things are good at
scale we have internet at scale cost
zero if you are not successful right now
you're in a bad spot because the playing
field is easier than it's ever been in
the history of the human race that's not
a dig I'm not interested in razzing I'm
not trying to be debbie [ __ ] downer
I'm trying to create a very logical
conversation that if you're not you need
to recognize that 80% likely you're
trying to make it happen too fast
because deep down you're so insecure
that you need financial success to cover
up your pain
or be you just might not be good at it
and what you should do is what a lot of
my friends did which they became
employee number 13 and 19 and 25 at
Facebook and uber and I promise you
employee number 54 at Facebook made more
money than every person in this room
including me right now self-awareness is
the most important conversation in our
society the rise of entrepreneurship and
the coolness has forced so many people
into thinking they need to be one
entrepreneurship is a skill no different
than playing a professional sport or
being a professional performer I implore
you to use tonight as an opportunity to
start finally being honest with yourself
and asking yourself a series of
questions around what you're good at and
what you like when somebody is lucky
enough to be great at what they like
they achieve ridiculous levels of
success most people are not fortunate
enough to have those Serendipity's
because they limit themselves from
trying things or they deploy delusion
around their ideology of what they wish
they were instead of looking at
themselves and figuring out what they
actually are I cannot be more clear in
my statement of how easy it is to be
successful on the internet today it's
just the truth I mean when I just think
about the ability to sell stuff on the
Internet and the infrastructure costs
being so low I just a passionate to make
sure everybody understands what's
happening in the macro which is very
simply nothing makes me laugh more than
when people get mad at the algorithms
for a platform that is [ __ ] free
people like the Sox is trying to [ __ ] me
sucks charge zero dollars for your
account we are doing an awful job in the
macro of understanding the opportunity
in front of us and more importantly when
we have something that works squeezing
the [ __ ] out of it and getting the most
value out of it so many people get upset
with platforms because they did get
there early enough
and it was easy and when it tightens up
because adspend comes in and starts
filling the feed they get sad that they
don't get the free impressions anymore
we have to we have to heed the moments
when I come up here and I articulate in
this mood not the mood that some of you
normally see me in around the
opportunity in LinkedIn the opportunity
in podcasts the opportunity and
influencer marketing many of you and
I've watched you shake your heads you
understand those truths you DAP each
other if you've been doing it a little
bit but the reality is are you going 120
on it do you understand that the target
moves do you understand that if I come
back here in 18 months
I mean look my last book I wrote
crushing it which only came out 18
months ago I didn't even mention
LinkedIn in the book wasn't even in the
book because that's how fast all of the
attention changes music lee's crushing
it three years ago with 13 year olds
then it dies because of them acquisition
then it reforms itself and comes back as
tick tock and now it really matters like
the speed in which this all is evolving
is enormous which means the capabilities
you need to have are enormous but this
starts with self-awareness and auditing
your skill set if you look at my career
from 1996 to today I have been on top of
and a contemporary and a great executor
of almost every shift except the one I
am silent from 2002 to 2006 because that
was the era when blogs exploded and I
can't write for [ __ ]
there is nobody who has five New York
Times bestselling books that writes
worse than me on earth the reason I
couldn't take advantage of blogs was I
couldn't write
I was self-aware enough that I couldn't
I didn't have the money or
infrastructure to hire a writer to do it
and so I had to take that Elle and Miss
that era with enormous frustration we do
not have that issue anymore because with
internet at scale written word audio and
video and the ability to go live with
your audience are all here you have the
ability to reverse engineer your
passions and strengths and deploy them
the problem is the framework that most
people have is fast and me it's fast and
what do I get
and it is obvious to me as I stand here
tonight that the unlock for the 90% in
this room is slow and then slow and then
and that's how I see the world how has
what happened to me happened because
every time I post it every single day
I'm trying to think about why would that
bring you value why do a lot of people
come to this event to see me it's
because I brought them value it's
because something I've said or done gave
them value I am fascinated by how every
single day I try to articulate in
different forms whether in cartoon form
and cursing form in audio form in
picture form how do I get people to
understand how enormous the opportunity
is and how amazing it is for us to be
alive during this era please use this
tone and by the way we're about to go to
Q&A so a couple things I know the mic is
over there so
anybody who wants to yep they're waving
their hands so anybody who wants to rush
this is it is your chance to ask the
question and line up over here so do not
be bashful do not regret it I'd really
want to go into the Q&A I've said what
I've had to say which is please don't
let this era go by please let me let me
put the real pressure on I am scared
that many of you will send me an email
and 15 years and say hey you probably
don't remember this but you were in
Sydney in 2019 you said all these things
and I didn't act on him and I wish I did
and I get those emails all the time
because I bring this up in a lot of my
talks over the last 15 years just don't
like please challenge yourself like if
it's not clicking right now it's not
going to get easier this is the easiest
that's ever been the economy globally
will go the other direction there was a
nice little blip in China just 48 hours
ago you get a couple more those blips
and it gets real hard real fast I just
am desperate for people to start
understanding they need to attack Sydney
please attack please please take my
focused energy this evening in
understanding that there's no reason to
be passive anymore in your communication
nothing matters more than communicating
on an everyday basis on the Internet
nothing nothing there's no system
there's no funnel nothing matters more
than bringing value to the end consumer
in content on a daily basis as an
awareness play to what you do for a
living
nothing it's called building brand it
takes a long time but it will absolutely
be the best thing that you possibly do
thank you
let's go hi Gary
how are you good thanks itself I'm
amazing
great so I own a company called logo
social the question I've got for years
should I be paid should I be focusing on
Sydney for paid advertising or should be
trying to hit like every major city
around the world well how are you doing
in Sydney to be honest a lot of our a
lot of our purchases are in Sydney and
in Paris so I'm trying to think if I
should be aiming more at Europe as well
or because of the time zones and the
different seasons well look i mean i
think wide and deep both work it just
comes down to your skill set i mean if
you think you're converting more
business in Europe for some rhyme or
reason then that's where you want to
focus you know what I mean I'm not I'm
unemotional about where business comes
from I just want to make sure that it's
not an ideology that you want to be
[ __ ] global and that's why you do it
I want to I'm hoping you're doing it
because it's in the best interest of
your business it's just it's just
because of like the summer here and the
winter they're just trying to make sales
and create content for each sort of
country and and making it work for us
I'm not sure what Mother Nature has to
do with this but what do you mean by
that
just for the different seasons I mean
you know this time of year it's winter
here so we're creating more you winter
content yeah yeah basically and it's
some over there and trying to create
content create you know clothing for
both sort of times a year it's spreading
across that yeah I don't see that as a
challenge like you know the reality is
that's the cost of entry right and if
we're the context of the market is
that's what you have to do so
alright thanks mate Hey hey Gary how are
you
good how are you tremendous awesome my
name is Nina's I run a small real estate
photography company okay um basically
I've consistently managed to beat my
current salary because I work full-time
as well okay my question is when is the
lawyer side hustle makes more money than
your actual job for the past six months
yes okay my question is ones like the
right time to quit the job now and go
full-time right now right now and before
everybody claps for you you may fail but
the reality is you can always get
another [ __ ] job ya can always get
another shitty job the time is now if
you're outperforming your regular job
with your side hustle you will be
dumbfounded by what actually happens
when you go full-time I only work about
two hours a day at it you mean at your
work no at my side hustle that's what I
mean when you convert that to thirteen
hours you're gonna you're gonna easily
Trump what you're doing in your regular
job salary above and beyond and closing
that gap sure [ __ ] love you man
love you basket Gary high-calorie my
name is Lucy Lane I'm the founder of
forest lane how are you I'm good thank
you
thank you so much for coming to Sydney
we're very excited I'm excited to be
here I [ __ ] love this city I have an
innovation marketing company and what we
do is a lot of marketing to emerging
technology companies and with this it's
all about taking new products and
services out to market initially if
they're you know using new technologies
like blockchain and smart cities et
cetera
how do you educate people who's in a
brand new space what's your best
educational methods of taking things out
to market I put out the content for free
you know what's unique about what I do
is I give away all vaynermedia secrets
on a deadly basis for free yeah and most
people think that's stupid
most people think the information they
have is what they're selling
I think the contextual execution is what
I sell and the way that we grow in new
areas is because I'm putting out the
content for free okay so I think you
should make white papers and videos and
podcasts about the information for free
okay and that's the best way of
educating brand new space of course
because when you're creating content at
scale and it just naturally educating
the market okay fantastic
thank you so much the other thing to
consider with a business like yours is
to do more work for free okay
people are unbelievably resistant to
doing free work but to me free work is
usually the gateway to paid work and the
amount of people that have audacity to
not do free work when nobody's [ __ ]
paying them blows my mind how much free
what can I do as much as you can bear
without eating instant noodles every
night noodles are delicious when you're
trying to get a caviar j:v how are you
my man I am really good very very good
ah look there's a big concern spending
two to three years you know with a lot
of hard work building up a brand across
these platforms only to have a platform
go obsolete is there a way to ensure you
know how's platforms come and go all the
hard work that we do know because people
are confused when you brand properly for
those two or three years you get the
brand value when I crush Twitter from
2007 to 11 I got the brand value even
though Twitter declined after that I
still know who Dane Cook and Tila
Tequila are because they crushed myspace
30 years ago like just cuz you don't
reach as many people organically doesn't
mean what you did for two or three years
didn't work you didn't keep your users
on television and print and radio and
billboards
we're not here to amass lists that we
can reach in perpetuity we're here to
build brand is
a strong way to transfer those users on
the platform to new platforms as they
come if you can see them declining yes
bring [ __ ] value to them while you've
got them on the platform and their
attention and they will [ __ ] find you
in a new [ __ ] thanks Gary you're welcome
like I like I you want to hear something
funny I wish everything that was
relevant right now disappeared and we
all started over tomorrow on paper calm
I mean the most followed [ __ ] in the
world hello hey hey Gary how are you
might I've got a innovation that has a
global patent on it and turn Australian
innovation okay and I want to get it at
scale globally there's 200 billion
products per annum in this face and this
innovation does like 15 innovations in
one and I'm wondering there's a lot of
Australian company owners here and
you're obviously a guy that's very
successful do you invest in Australian
businesses and Australian companies and
do you ever look at a product that might
come from out of Australia where I
started marketing when I was about 19 I
was an early investor in canva okay
another Australian cut like sure I don't
give a [ __ ] where it comes from if it's
good I'm interested good we had a thing
called our over-seasoned undersold I
studied when I was 19 now 46 and
literally Australia's got a really good
innovation hub here I'd love to talk to
you or get in contact with your staff at
some stage thank you mate
you're welcome pledging hi Gary ello
Sydney thank you my name is Meg I have a
activewear brand called duck rillette ik
okay my question is how to stay fresh
and relevant in an oversaturated
industry by innovating product or your
communication mm-hmm it's not super
complicated it's the same game that Nike
or Under Armour or adidas have battled
for you know every fashion brand
there's only when you have a brand like
that there's only two ways you win you
innovate product or you innovate the way
you communicate to the end consumer all
right I'm trying to do guys I've been
pulling on the advice got a podcast
going and
it seems to be working pretty well I
have a second question I'm about to move
to London and I want to come and work
for vaynermedia how do I do that you
apply obviously any tips to stand up you
know it's funny we we don't have it
we're really kind of funny in the way we
hire we go in all sorts of different
directions I would say this I think I
think Vayner is very much a people
organization I would probably go follow
all the people that work at London
there's about a hundred of them and see
if you have common interests with any of
them
and engage in those conversations on
Twitter and other platforms with them
and use that as a gateway to awareness
of you and then use that to apply thanks
Gary you're welcome okay Liam I'm 19
from Perth nice to meet you
yeah you too I'll give you a quick
summary basically 2018 I was diagnosed
with Hodgkin's lymphoma if you don't
know that is thank you
yep well so I did about six months
chemotherapy a few weeks of radiation
therapy and it was like one of the
hardest things I've had to do in my life
of course post coming out of that I
basically realized [ __ ] this I don't
want to work a normal job and it just
made me realize everyday is not
guaranteed pretty much so I decided to
start my own gym wear apparel company my
goal is to basically create a symbol of
like strength and a label that people in
my position can like wear and gain
strength and basically realize that they
can make it through whatever they're
going through okay my question is I do
want to eventually at some point be able
to donate free clothes to these people
my concerns are that one should I wait
for my brain to actually be big enough
to mean something or should I just like
cut the [ __ ] start doing it now when
it's not really built it doesn't really
matter if the punchline of the product
is to inspire them and give them courage
and you have an established that brand
then you're just giving them clothes
yeah so I you know usually I'm a as you
can tell and you probably know I tend to
be like now but I think the way you
framed it up it wouldn't
for you to actually build the storyline
because it's that logo that's gonna
actually deliver what you're trying to
deliver yep totally awesome um second
question is I just bought a hoodie for
me as well to give to you if you
wouldn't mind I'd love to give it to you
after or you can give it to me now
that's what I'll grab it for you thanks
guys
hey going Gary my name is Nathan Nathan
how are you yeah good thanks um you seem
pretty chill and yeah on top of things
so my question is how do you handle
stress and adversity in your businesses
by realizing it doesn't mean dick I mean
it I have never been able to really get
down on business because I basically
make pretend in my mind when something
awful happens in business that instead
of this awful thing that happened we had
a great day but I got a phone call that
one of the ten people I love the most
died in a horrific accident and it just
wakes me up and puts me in person a very
big perspective I am unbelievably not
interested in money
I do not validate myself I'm not
interested in flashy [ __ ] I'm into the
game money is great that's fine it
rewards a lot of opportunity but the
stress is easy when you don't have your
emotions wrapped up in the success of
your business yeah like I love doing
business like the reason I garage sale
or go do a week at a baseball card show
like I just did is because I love the
process not the gifts that are given to
me personally from the business so the
stress that I get from business is
extremely low because I'm not scared to
go to zero yeah makes sense you
understand yeah and that if you go
deeper is grounded in the fact that I
don't give a [ __ ] what anybody thinks
about me
if I completely collapse and go to zero
and everybody here and all of social and
all of internet says see he was full of
[ __ ] he wasn't good
I generally wouldn't care yeah I just
have no interest in living my life based
on other people's opinions thank you
I just think you need to put business in
perspective
like and also I'm thankful for playing
like the cost of entry of being an
entrepreneur is having ridiculously
difficult days you want to live your
life on your own terms of course it
should be hard otherwise we'd all be
doing it perspective
thanks you got it Hey I work for did you
owe me a company called fisheye creative
in Newcastle okay the question is so I
have no interest in being the business
owner or the entrepreneur I want to be
the best number two I love that I and I
would like to know what you would say to
your number two what's the best way to
add to the productivity and the value of
the company and to assist the number one
by reverse engineering the number one
shortcomings by sorry by reverse
engineering the number ones shortcomings
okay the best thing a number two can do
is close the gaps of a number one so are
you a good match to your number one yes
well then that's a good starting point
you know to me it's about complementary
skills at that level and so it's just
you know a lot of times number two
struggle because they want to do or
they're as or they're equally have the
same talents as the number one and
that's where friction comes from I think
it's a game of complementary skills and
so the the relationships that I've seen
and the ones that have worked for me is
when the number two is filling in the
blanks of the number one and allowing
the number one to do her or his magic
thank you you're welcome I really
appreciate you validating that it's okay
not to be the entrepreneur as well I
appreciate that yeah you know my great
fear is that as entrepreneurship has
gotten popular
obviously that's been directly a benefit
to me but I have no interest in anybody
aspiring to be one when they're not in
the same way that I take a lot of issue
with people thinking that going to
university is the way to go
like we have to we have to change the
conversation and make this about
happiness and self-awareness not [ __ ]
money yeah thank you
hi Gary it's me Mitchell from Sydney how
are you
fantastic thank you hell you're really
really good I've got a hashtag question
for you care ok we develop residential
property in a regional town called
Oberon New South Wales okay and if the
hashtag Oberon New South Wales isn't
popular yet what do you do to grow a
hashtag that people wouldn't search for
it unless they knew about it why would
you want it to be popular well I'd want
people to see a small regional town of
3,600 people getting 200 million dollars
into it as popular despite its size but
why would you do that in the form of
making a hashtag popular who are more
into people finding the town and
organically looking at why they should
invest money in my project in that town
well you should do that by putting out
content to build awareness because the
hashtag is not gonna do that for you so
content specific for the town or content
of developments or why should invest in
general yes general
both you know a hashtag is a tactic that
isn't ownable I can I can put out a post
right now of why people should invest in
soccer and proper football cards and put
that hashtag in my post hashtags are not
honorable
and they're not the discovery tool that
you assume they are you should run
creative in the form of videos and
probably white papers and decks and then
you should target them against
development investors so target the
white papers with the content
and then and Targo the bleep down the
funnel if you're looking for investors
you may want to go into Instagram and go
against funds that invest in
developments not put all your energy in
trying to get a hashtag popular an
Instagram and Twitter that will lead to
nothing wonderful thank you you're
welcome
strategy [ __ ] yes sir I Gary
I'm I'm Timmy nice to meet you I've just
recently started my own podcast okay and
my question is geared towards something
I've heard you say about quantity
unlocking quality yes I was there like a
moment in time from when you started
doing I am you know what video was with
Wine Library where there was a moment in
time we just clicked or did you navigate
through like becoming better speaking on
camera or speaking to an audience I
think I had that natural ability you
know if you look at the first 60
episodes of Wine Library TV in 2006 I
was more reserved even maybe the
demeanor I'm having tonight that was
predicated on me worrying that a lot of
the people that were spending $100,000
with me in wine as a 28 year old would
be scared off by my ridiculousness but
the gift of gab and having charisma and
being a storyteller and having a comfort
with people was just naturally in me but
there's a lot of people who are not as
over-the-top as me that are massively
successful because they're their
authentic self and you don't need to be
a showman to have a top podcast you know
Tim Ferriss has an incredible podcast
he's not over the top so what you need
to do is lean into your DNA not try to
have a moment where you click and become
over you know a different version of
yourself I was also just thinking in
terms of your city or yourself or myself
developer know yours was would you
review what your videos are now doing
I've never watched a piece of my content
that's what I do
yeah I have no interest I [ __ ] did it
good I know what's in it good that's how
I feel good thanks brother hey hey Gary
how are you hey good thanks how are you
super awesome my name is David I'm a
banker I don't know what you mentioned
that you don't really give a [ __ ] what
people think of you but what do you tell
people that you care about when they
tell you to maybe chill out or calm down
or take it easy how do you deal with
that because you actually care about
them I tell I tell them that I that I
love that and I appreciate where they're
coming from but I have no interest in
telling them how to live their lives
so I'd appreciate if they told me not
how to live mine also awesome thank you
you got it hey Gary my name is Chris
welcome to Sydney I don't want to say
thank you thank you work thank you bro I
thought I'll bring some value to the
room for smaller business owners how do
they make content SQL with limited
budget because I work in the creative
space but we're higher t-one top
companies and stuff but I just want you
to elaborate and for smaller business
owners how do they keep up to this such
an demanding social media space Facebook
Instagram and a lot by auditing all the
dumb [ __ ] that they and their employees
do all day and turn that into making
content thank you you're welcome
I mean listen like I get those emails
all the time and I'm like you know some
story mailed me the other day and I went
back and forth with her and I said do
you have cashiers she said yeah I go how
many are on during a normal shift she
said - I said are they busy she said of
course not I'm like select and make
content like the amount of time that you
actually are wasting in a day on dumb
[ __ ]
including myself all of us is
extraordinary anybody who tells me Gary
I just watched your keynote on YouTube
how do I find time to make all that
content I reply with don't watch an hour
of my [ __ ] keynote
hey hey Gary thank you so much for
adding so much value to us in Sydney
today and for coming down I'm done thank
you for saying that I'm Mary Jane my
company's paper Phoenix and I own a
marketing and public relations agency
fix it
my question is around authenticity now
being someone who controls another dozen
people's social media accounts humans
yes absolutely about authenticity right
so that's my question is all these apps
have come out now with automatically
replying for your social media accounts
or even liking and you don't even know
what they're liking
do you think it's a great idea to invest
or keep the authenticity really real no
matter how long it takes me to be
authentic for my clients you're not
authentic if you're speaking on behalf
of somebody who's not you you're just a
human version of those [ __ ]
piece-of-shit products the question
I didn't think about it right you're
you're putting judgment on a machine
that is liking or doing all these hacks
that a lot of people love to do and they
don't realize that at the end of the day
that's gonna [ __ ] them because it just
kills the soul
oh great but meanwhile you're writing on
behalf of another human being correct
but that's that's when you try to get
into their business and understand their
business and not happening either all
right change my job you say you you
could do whatever you want I think it's
way worse for them than it is for you
you know
I laugh when people don't think it's me
when I reply to them you know it's it's
the main reason I get to stand on this
stage is cuz it was always me often
tissa t is only achievable when it's
actually authentic wonderful thank you
so much you got it so I have a question
about investing because I'm just
thinking about starting to invest but I
don't like it to be something that I'm
actually interested in smart have you
looked into vagin companies but yes
because I know a lot of people say it's
a trend but I think in 10 20 years it's
not just a trend I know it's not an
abate it's in perpetuity yes I reckon
it's a good idea starting to investing
like let's say beyond me or whatever
type of company it is yeah the problem
is like there's a lot of people that
think how do you think so there's yes I
think there'll be vegan based companies
that are successful in next 20 years I
also think that 98% of them will fail
but I do like I do like the idea of
investing in places that you know or
passionate about okay I do like that I
think you're welcome I think that's I do
like where you're going with that I just
want to make sure that you realize
because it's a macro trend there'll be a
lot of losing not everybody gets to win
yes just like a lot of people have lost
in social media but the macro trend was
right yes got it thank you
Hey I carry my name's Elizabeth Ann
Walker thank you for coming thank you I
love your heart
thank you I hope I love your scarf
thank you I hope people realize and
actualize their dreams and in 2008 I got
on social media for the first time
because this weird guy from New York
told me to I've built a business at that
time it saved my life literally it did
it was the only way I could communicate
with people because I walked away from
someone who'd hurt me that should have
loved me I understand nine days ago you
told us what you told me to get on tick
tock
the first video I did is now up to 63
thousand views so thank you how do I
make that happen for the other videos
because they're sitting between 200 and
a thousand so I want to know what's the
strategy the first video was hey is
there anyone from Australia on this app
because I can't see any Australians here
it's gone wild what do I need to do to
act to actualize this platform because I
freaking love it I think you just need
to keep making great you know think
about it your first lawyer it's just a
volume yeah you gotta try things go the
biggest struggle this collective room
has is they don't break out of their box
cuz they're worried about judgment or
they're worried about short-term success
yeah when you didn't know any better you
made the best video you've made
yeah you understand yeah my kids were
like no you can't be a horse I like
every time I do this I get a huge influx
of kids saying you [ __ ]
you know this was my place you know I'm
like sorry marketers ruin everything
so just keep me keep trying [ __ ] awesome
thank you you got it thank you thanks
for the kind words hey guys my name's
Ben hey Ben my question is how do you
get the most out of your team from day
to day to week to week yeah how do you
put it put a fire under their ass and
get the most out of it by realizing that
I work for them not the other way around
I think most people suck at being bosses
because they think that their employees
Oh them something for what they pay them
for and I think of it the other way
around which is I pay them and I owe it
to them to put them in a position to
succeed so I spend all my time listening
and understanding whether it's positive
word reinforcement finances work-life
balance
title or whatever it might be that
actually makes them go most people have
a one-size-fits-all most people try to
make their employees act like them and
it's the biggest mistake of all time
people would be stunned if they came to
vaynermedia of how few people are in the
office at 6 p.m. from somebody that
hustles I don't hold my employees
accountable to my framework I'm in the
business of listening to them on an
individual basis to figure out how to
get them motivated and happy do you want
to forget one more quick one if you say
two events or you maybe take on a new
client or whatever it may be how do you
get them excited and see the passion and
the vision that you want to instill
within this event or the client or
something a new project at the employee
level or at the client level yeah so you
you know I take on clients I look after
different media projects if I take on
someone I see this grand vision but say
it in flooring products and generally we
work with florists you know how do I
really start installing that vision and
and try to portray something long-term
to the client no sorry I've solved the
client - to my staff who are managing
the account who are creating the content
who are you know looking at my vision by
firing the ones that don't okay okay do
you understand yeah elimination a
hundred percent people confused hiring
is guessing firing is knowing yeah
Cheers
five years to that [ __ ]
yo yo I'm just gonna read this because
I'm nervous and obviously although I
don't go ahead a few years ago I was
going through a really rough time in my
life and I was trying a whole lot of
things and I was getting a whole lot of
[ __ ] from friends like my closest
friends yes they're not my friends
anymore good at that time all of that
was happening was in 2016 was at the
time when I heard about use and started
learning off your content one of the
things I decided to try and I'm now
continuing and pushing hard is my
lifelong passion of music and so I wrote
a song called winning this game which
actually features a recording of one of
your quotes and it has you in it
because it was it's so relevant and
helped me so much thank you
it sounded a little bit like find new
friends I'm being dead serious about
this you're whatever you are whatever of
your five closest friends that [ __ ] put
it in a [ __ ] bank so the question I
have is actually to ask a permission to
have it featured on my song dan if I can
give you this piece of paper to remind
you to listen to it and as I put my
heart and soul into it and I know you
will love it and thank you for so much
for being so inspirational
the plan is real thank you the
permission is granted yeah don't give me
the paper cuz I'll lose it but if you if
you email me in the title say I'm the
dude that came to the mic and told you
about this like put it all in the title
and put the link in the in the body and
I'll listen to it okay
cool awesome mate thank you let me get
five I'm gonna send it a little bit Hey
hey Gary Christine from peanut butter
bar been stalking you for the last two
weeks how are you how are you I heard
our video made you smile somehow yes my
question to you is regarding rebranding
so that we are the world's first peanut
butter dessert bar and to easy and we've
now realized we have to change direction
and our brand ID my question is
regarding rapport and credibility what
happens to all our customers and all the
hype that we've created over the last
two years and how do we kind of continue
with that credibility make the campaign
very predicated on the name change right
like you make it a fun positive event
and so what you need to like when you
completely rebrand you know complete
like what are you gonna rebrand - well
the name will stay the same but the ID
will change so we're currently very
nation now we're going into a more of a
mass kind of approach so we're moving
from fitness to sort of peanut butter
obsession helped me a little more
because I want to give you the right
answer you've been doing what we've been
focused on the fitness market so sort of
high protein desserts dumbbells and
muscles always sort of dropping that and
going into peanut butter attic universe
and so what are you worried about well
we're changing the logo we're changing
the ID sort of the communication and
we're just worried about the credibility
so we've taken people on a journey for
two years and now we kind of you know
pivoting to another communication and
you'd like to keep them as what you're
saying we want to keep the ones that
we've created up until now but we also
and we don't want to sort of lose the
faith and the end of sort of a
relationship we've built with these
existing customers but when you change
your tone that's inevitably gonna happen
with a percentage of them so just
continue on and sort of try and create a
new universe around the brand it's a
decision you've already made fair enough
do you understand that no understand I'm
just worried about credibility because
will you beat that decision fair enough
like you know get it I get it
good like once you've made that decision
and you've done it for it sounds like in
my opinion probably good reasons you
can't have your cake and eat it too
you're trying to go to a broader market
and you're gonna lose a percentage of
your niche market when you make that
transition which is trying to be greedy
I guess trying to sort of read your
[ __ ] sucks
what you're being is ideological and
hopeful and that's fine but if you spent
every second that you just asked me that
question about how to make sure the new
audience grow so fast that you never
feel that you lost any percentage of
your old audience you'd be in a much
better place you see where I'm going
yeah that's what you have to do once
you've made the decision you need to put
all your eggs in that basket not be
hopeful of what will happen and that's
where a lot of people get caught
they they can't deal with the one step
backwards for the two steps forward and
what I'm trying to do is get you into a
mindset of being obsessed with three
steps forward so you don't even feel the
one step backwards listen thank you all
really appreciate it thank you you got
it
hello hey guy how are you I'm Sean Sean
how are you good thank you
just to give you context about me I'm a
sub teacher that's important because I
gave up at their work to be here today
inspired me to make my own podcast with
a friend of mine we target sixteen to
thirty year olds we talk conspiracies
trends current affairs try and add some
comedic value to it
we do my own version of trash talk and
show the kids and adults that we can
make extra income and update the
listeners on my wins and my losses along
the way I like that but also I want to
talk sports education and give advice
where I've qualification to do so so my
question is should I put all the topics
under the same umbrella
yes should i branch out and create other
channels and other brands No would it be
optimal to keep everyone under the same
umbrella so that are the same listeners
yes okay cool thank you very much thank
you I think I think in a world that were
in now the uniqueness of your hodgepodge
and potpourri of subject matters is your
strengths not your weakness and if you
created for brands you sink so right now
I'm 16 and in high school and I want to
be an entrepreneur just like using all
that okay so what advice would you give
me with like checking like completely
disregard school and focused all in
entrepreneurship
yeah yep a personal brand yes I mean you
know but I I would if you think you're
an entrepreneur you need to find out and
you're and I don't think 16 is too young
to know this you need to really ask
yourself if you're trying to force
yourself to be an entrepreneur because
it's cool
or if it's who you actually are yeah
wanting to be one I want to be a [ __ ]
quarterback of the New York Jets
wanting something versus being capable
of it are two very different things if
you truly are an entrepreneur yes I
think you can punch school yeah if
you're doing it cuz it's the thing now
then you're gonna be vulnerable yeah
yeah I'm just doing it's like get ahead
get out of the rat race that's an
ideology yeah
rat race of what life like [ __ ]
school that makes you do nothing that's
not a rat race that's a [ __ ] vacation
bro yeah it's possible for you but I
just want to make sure that you're not
being ideological about it and it's like
you know like you know I just you know I
just want to make sure a lot of kids
like you I'm gonna do this I'm like cool
are you good it's selling stuff do you
have a good idea are you willing to put
in the work ethic a lot of kids that
suck at school look at entrepreneurship
as the vacation entrepreneurship is way
[ __ ] harder to school yeah are you
good at selling [ __ ] Yeah right now I
have like Instagram account have like
80,000 folds I uploaded like music and
do you make funny bro yeah how much so I
thought about four thousand in the past
three months just for my shoutouts to
start yeah
quit school yeah thanks you got it
good eye today my question is in a world
where business is about giving what is
the right motivation for attempting to
make profit as opposed to just being a
charity um because you want to again
like there's nothing wrong with it
making profit in the same way that
there's nothing wrong with you know
being fully in a charity mindset you
know the the motivation is you chose to
for whatever reason okay you know what I
mean yeah I think this is something that
some people struggle with you know it's
funny when I wrote Jab Jab Jab right
hook I thought I was writing it for
people that were just always spamming
and I needed to show them how to bring
value so that they could close their
sale but I realized that the writing it
was it was really written for people
that always give value and it gave them
permission to ask for a sale there's
nothing wrong with generating profit
because at the end of the day if you
choose that that's what you want to do
then that's more than okay I think doing
good is a competitive advantage for
businesses you know okay thank you very
much welcome we're gonna do a couple
more I'm sorry they've I've been
overtime for a while now go ahead hey
Gary how are you
Arjun from investigate a buyer's agency
for residential and commercial investors
I just wanted to say a massive massive
thank you because you have enabled me to
just focus so hard on reinvesting in
myself and in business I haven't taken a
dollar for myself for like the last year
and it's just been phenomenal yes but um
where the business is now is I really
want to scale out with different
solutions of technology and education
but at the same time I have my core
business a buyer's agency okay a part of
me goes do you put them under different
brands and try and connect them but then
a part of me goes know you're building
this community and you can help them in
so many ways how do you sort of make
these types of decisions you don't feel
like you're cramming your audience or
too much at the same time you could
separate it
you pick a decision because both could
work and you live with it go I think so
do you feel that sometimes you can
create a brand disconnect from putting
too many things or in your experience of
scaling and adding services and products
how did not if you were able to execute
you know when Apple decided to make a
phone and not just an iPod that worked
because it was good yeah nothing cool
the whole games for everybody I like for
all of us is execution you couldn't do
anything if you do it well thank you so
much man I mean everybody told me to
stay in the wine business and I would
never be successful in advertising that
seemed like far-fetched and disconnected
I just thought I could do it well and so
the answer is yes if you can execute
last one cool hey Jerry I teach people
how to sing better and I absolutely love
it
okay gradually growing it but I'm not
making enough to take care of my mom
he's got a disability so hey my question
is from your experience is this just a
game of patience maybe and what I mean
by that is what I would really audit is
every other minute
besides you teaching people to sing and
you having to do another job in addition
to help a mother who's disabled you know
what I mean yeah it may be you'll click
and get the right client to get you
another 30 clients and all of a sudden
you know right there the other option
you have is to audit every other hour
that you have that isn't in the full
time job and the side hustle of singing
that may allow you to do more of the
singing stuff do you see what I mean
yeah like usually the thing when people
have to do two things that they have to
focus on is auditing their leisure so
that they can pour more time into their
side hustle so that the side hustle can
actually grow while they're keeping
something that makes the practicality of
their short-term needs viable
cool thank you so much in the way that
those questions went I think half the
time its affirmation I think the other
half of the time is my lack of education
and my lack of paying attention to other
voices has created an extremely simple
framework where the answer is simple and
they weren't looking for affirmation
they just had so many contradictory
thoughts that getting the simplicity of
the answer just created clarity
I think the far majority of people
overthink [ __ ] and so it's either
affirmation or its simplicity
excellent I set you up to not as if you
were going to be a like a bat out of
hell
I heard how often you in this really
connected peaceful power like one in
every like twenty to thirty talks this
comes out and I'm always interested in
it you know there's its it's not
predicated on being tired you know I
always think when I do this I'm like do
they think that it was like it's
predicated on I'm in mid thought you
know a lot of times where when it
happens I can feel myself in a zone
where I'm just so quiet and it doesn't
you know I also very thoughtful what I
mean by that is this is now the third
time I'm it's Sydney in you know a ye in
less than two and a half years and so
I'm always thoughtful of most of this
room whether they've seen it physically
here or online have gotten the energy
thing I thought tonight you know I think
of myself as somebody who's trying to
find different angles to connect and I
think this tone with this information
tonight for a lot of people might be not
disappointing but sometimes when you go
see your favorite band you want to hear
the hits right and other times you want
to hear something else and for me I'm
desperate to get people to win
and if I can throw this off-speed pitch
or curveball and because I did this was
the time something penetrated their mind
because the beat of the cadence of what
I normally do has become mundane and
they're used to it I'm always trying to
do things that bring value and
intuitively tonight here I felt this was
the right tone and tenor and that's what
I went with him said hey thank you so
much I love you guys
Darrin Garda Chuck
[Applause]